so s nimmst du wen ich nehme Yoshi oh
wie nehme ich w nehme ich eigentlich
musst Donkey Kong nehmen also wir
spielen zu viert ich bin Yoshi sandra
ist diese komische
Taschenmuschi Donkey Kong und Peach sind
die Computern wir stellen die mal auf
Normal ich werde dich von hinten
auseinander nehmen spielt zum ersten Mal
auf diesem Brett ja ne oder hast du
schon mal drauf gespielt brauchen wir
nicht doch se wir lassen uns jetzt
einmal die Spiele nachher haben wir
wieder Fragen nein haben wir nicht
das Regel alles klar aber wenn eine
einzige Frage stellt muss die 20
Liegestütze machen so wie ich die ganze
Zeit in Minecraft loser okay okay ja
komm selfie
springing mal spring du maling mal
selfie spring jetzt spring spring
du wir haben nicht mal angefangen es
geht spring jetzting ich spring nicht
als erstes ich will sehen was du h
ja einach mir egal ich spring nicht n
ich h nicht ich auch nicht mir
scheißegal den Stream e okay ich zähle
jetzt runter und jetzt muss man springen
okay okay 3 2
1 warum springst du
nicht selber nicht die Reg e das ist
doch wieder so ein Scheiß dieser Stream
hier Sandra ich zähle ich will h
anfangen wir zählen jetzt runter und
jetzt springen wir wirklich okay
wirklich
ja okay wer nicht springt macht zehn
Liegestütz okay D Z
ein bitte springen bitte springen schon
wieder so ist schon wieder so eine
Prinzip da ich werd nicht springen ich w
auch nicht springen e komm ich spring
jetzt okay springst du dann auch ja okay
ich spring wirklich ich auch also real
ich springe jetzt wir müssen jetzt
anfangen komm spring jetzt auch okay D Z
ein ich spring nicht zuerst ich spring
nicht zuerst ich auch nicht 2000 Jahre
später okay wer zuletzt springt ist ein
Wicher nein es war so klar Mist WD ist
am Zug
ja ja sollen wir den Chat ausblenden
Leute er gibt eigentlich am meisten Sinn
glaube ich ne mittig und mit Chat
ausblenden machen was so dann machen wir
die Cam mittig und Blenden den Chat
einfach aus ich glaube so ist am
sinnvollsten oder ja okay dann seht ihr
eure Nachrichten zwar nicht im Youtube
Video nachher aber istal okay ich bin D
mit Würfeln ich gucke denat hier
schreibt aber keiner
rein ein einzelchat hier gerade bei mir
was ist denn das für ein
Scheiß bin ich nervös kurz Strecken ich
bin
dabei
Lua du nervst mich einfach ja warum Sam
ich sie
nicht ja
erste ich bin so dermaßen
schlecht mein Gott ich bin ja voll
langsam D dass ich so vi
g
die auf
Diät ich bin so da macht mal Handy jetzt
wirklich auf
leiserer ich bin insgesamt se Schritte
weit gekommen wie geht das
Spiel komisch wollt ja vor nicht die
Regeln
anschauen
[Musik]
stabil schei hat man nur eine
Chance oh mein
Gott
Ciao diger was macht der denn was macht
der
[Musik]
denn oh mein Gott der ist ja genauso
dran wie
ich also ich war ja so schlecht hat man
nur eine Chance Laser ich weiß nicht ob
man noch eine zweite hat ja hat man
nur mein Gott ja
letzter Ende das
war's
scheiße ich schon wieder gewonnen
Scheiße Leute habe ich jetzt verkackt ne
dann 10 Liegestütze ja eigentlich ja hat
eine Frage gestellt ne wie das geht
wir Zen am Ende muss 20 sicher ja okay
Leute merkt euch
20 die hat
erst
oder 20 trotzdem leisten ich hab ich
kein Problem ich bin einfach
Geistes
Leute ich
bintist das
jetzt gerne Klau von irgendwem W den die
meisten
ach du kannst nicht von mir klauen ich
habe ja gar kein Nein
[Musik]
Münzen ja Leute es ist nicht immer es
ist nicht immer
wichtig
ja ist frech bisher da gewinnt man zwei
Minispiele und die kommen auf glüeld die
hat mir Sterne
geklaut
noch lösch meine Nummer ich bin einfach
Geistes es ist einfach ehrenlos bisher
nein guck mal die Sache ist la ich bin
halt heftig gut in dem
[Musik]
Spiel guck mal da hast noch zum
Ding
ich geb drei Münzen du kannst aber auch
auch nur eine geben ach so nee umso
öfter du vorbeig gehst glaube ich umso
öfter muss man auch Ding
ehrlich glaub ja
ereignisf wenn das jetzt was negatives
ist
ne ach du
scheiße ist der Stern ist woanders
wahrscheinlich ist der Stern jetzt
direkt vor Sandy so wie ich die
kenne
ich bin da so
peinlich ja das ist einfach als wä ich
betrunken da läuft mich
genauso
sauberen ach ich dachte dadurch dass ich
jetzt schon im Ziel
bin
sind die ander auch schon bodenlos
verloren also ich war ja mit Abstand die
schlechteste wie weit bin ich denn jetzt
vom Stern entfernt
22 bitte nicht
GTA GTA gespielt wir haben Vers
[Musik]
Spiel mich gar nicht bewegt nein ich
habe jetzt 28 Münzen bekommen fün Blöcke
nur mal haben
wir soll ich nicht kaufen Sandy auf
nicht wenn du heftig bist drück mal Nein
Danke und dann trotzdem gewinnen das wä
krassin ich bin raus s du musst es
Regeln du musst es Regeln
Sandy
weiter nach rechts was machst du denn
komm Don
bitteid ein gegen PE verloren das ist
wirklich sehr sehr
[Musik]
traurig ich bin dran jetzt erstmal kurz
Stern Bo ne 25 Sterne weit ist der Weg
Plätze weit
krass
soll ich von einemem Stern klauen ja
gern oh ich dich ne ich ich bin
raus ich bin raus ich bin raus ja okay
Münzen ist in Ordnung Klau mich kau
mich ich glaub checkt nicht ne was denn
du kannst ganz oft A drücken dann macht
der
weniger die 16 Stück gemobst du kleiner
Hohn
[Musik]
so wie es aussieht ja ist ja gar nicht
so
schnell Leute ich habe einfach noch
nicht einmal
getroffen e oh mein Gott Leute ich habe
meine Figur
verwechselt
oh mein Gott ich weiß ich kann es gar
nicht einschätzen ich glaub ich war
ziemlich schlecht ich glaub ich war nein
nein nein ich war die
schlechteste oh mein Gott
Sandra wir haben verkackt was soll ich
dir sagen
wieso wir hab jeder ein Stern aus Donkey
Kong aber es ist
halt haben so viele gespielt dann habe
ich mir das bei vielen Leuten auch
angeguckt will ich selbst nicht mehr
spielen Leute ich bin ja so dermaßen
schlecht 32 zum Stern ey das ist doch
wirklich ich auch
und glücksfeld aber ich habe genügend
Dings sieben Münzen wow genug Münz halt
halt die Fresse wollte ich dir gerade
auch
sagen
B Zeit gleich oh mein
Gott
diger diger jetzt läuft die meine Linie
da kaputt ich könn
kotzen Unentschieden ja Nein
echt
ich freue mich dass ich jetzt wieder am
Zug bin und ich werde
oh mein Gott und ich kann es mir nicht
mal leisten oh mein Gott h du wenig
Münzen ne ja Bo guck mal die macht die
ganze Zeit Ansagen ne und scheißt so
rein ne jetzt krieg wahrscheinlich
wieder ein Stern ich wurde so ja
was hey ich Münzen und bin wieder
39 Sterne
entfernt wie viel habe ich zum fünf guck
mal ma ich doch
easy wichtig so wichtig oh mein Gott oh
mein
Gott we Luca das jetzt näich die letzte
Runde
ne was für letzte
Runde Runde 8 von 20 wir spielen aber
nicht 20 natürlich das eine Stunde
Runde lu wer wer wer bringt mich nach
Hause gute Frage jetzt will ich aber mal
sehen ne besser als 1890 musst du
machen
diger ja das schaffe ich niemals
[Musik]
doch
nein junge so
wichtig oh mein
Gott Leute ein Spiel worin ich einmal
besser war oh mein
Gott
takes
ja es gibt so viele Spiele s ich müssen
so viel noch
spielen im Herbst ich sag's euch wenn es
draußen kalt ist dann dann geht's los ja
la du bist jetzt da hol den zweiten ja
ma ich
[Musik]
Laser was machen wir denn jetzt wie was
machen wir
jetzt SP wir das jetzt echt durch müssen
wir es ist natürlich schon blöd wenn man
dann in Minecraft irgendwie wieder so
hohen Turm baut wenn man dann g kN
gebaut itemfeld gibt gar keine
Spielpartner
mehr
spring auf ein
Fass das ist wie dieses kackspiel weißt
du was ist das denn okay und Ende
und warum hast du denn jetzt einfach
random
gewonnenus das Feld mit einem zufällig
ausgewählten
[Musik]
spielerr geht schon
los
ja diger schaff ich ja
niemals ja das kann man gar nicht
schaffen ja wow wie soll das
gehen ja
h oh mein Gott ich hab geschafft hast
geschafft hätte ich auch nicht gedacht
lol ja Leute das wird
heute nachtchallenge wir sind nicht mal
bei der
Hälfte ich fin es auch so korrupt dass
dieser Würfel sich einfach dreht und er
hat offensichtlich nur sechs Leute ich
habe keine Lust mehr der Stern ist immer
so geisteskrank entfernt ich war einmal
da hatte kein Geld guck mal Sandy ich
habe
22 Felder zum Stern entfernt deswegen
tausche ich jetzt dem zufäigen
Spieler ja mit Sandy wie weit ist sie
weg ach 17 dicker wow guck mal der
Würfel der irgendwie Z verschiedene
Zahlen aber nur sechs verschiedene
Flächen ich check nicht na gut bin ich
ja zumindest ein bisschen ner dran ich
geh jetzt nicht da
lang komm ich kauf mal ein
Item ich holle me glückalür ich habe e
genug Geld
Leute
[Musik]
Laser muss arbeiten kann leider nicht
schauen morgen
PP fliegt wirklich nicht mehr
persönliches Pech
was was wie ich nee hier im Chat weil
jemand arbeiten
muss Lua ruf mal Privatchat an und mich
na Hause zu fahren gleich heute ich
sitze im ich sit im Flugzeug s gerade
gelandet auf einmal sehe ich so ein Jet
steht da wo steh Laser an der Seite dran
Laser weißt du wie wir das machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
können dit man nur Münzen für sich
selbst also wie kann man denn gewinnen
PE Bower verkleidet in der
Mitte oh mein Gott mein Burger ist da
hier
nein noch dre Münzen ich mussz
mehr
moin da sind wir wieder Freunde so
vorhersb gewonnen wir haben gewonnen
ne
Laser wir haben wie soll ich nach Hause
kommen was ist denn oder wollen wir
Zwischending machen wir spielen Runde
15 ja meine Schwester ist e schon
gefahren die haben oben gewartet weil
die alle zusammen gegessen
haben die ist eh schon gefahren der
Stream sollte doch est in einer Minute
Enden ja aber ich habe schon 5 Minuten
gesagt so fah
spielen ja die Sand zwingt sich mal zu
den Livestreams Leute nein tue ich nicht
aber es kann mich halt keiner
abholen unbeding
Führerschein
ein boah ich habe richtig
rasiert oh mein
Gott ich habe so
rasiert
ja schau mal an GU mal die kommen immer
mehr ich bin zweit
geworden scheiße ich bin schon bei
solchen Spielen ja komm wir machen bis
Runde 15 dann schauen wir wer die
meisten Sterne hat wenn so weitergt
Laser Laca ne
ja dann bin ich richtig am Arsch
diger W du tauscht mit
mir e check dir ich habe 112
Münzen du willst mich auseinander
nehmen kann das nicht mehr oh mein Gott
ich bin so
sauer das war ja so
schlecht zeig Burger sieht nicht gut
aus vegan
oder chicken alternative genommen
schmeckt nicht
geil oh mein
Gott ja ich ich ma jetzt
aus es macht jetzt schon keinen Sinn
mehr oh mein
Gott
[Musik]
ne
Lukas macht keinen
Sinn Alter ich bin sauer
ne oh mein Gott
blöd ich ist zu leicht mit euch die
taschenm die besse ne mus ich mit Ring
am Finger dre
[Musik]
schön du hast mir noch nicht geschrieben
was für ein GTA du hast ah ja check ich
g
noch schau an alle die schlafen müssen
wegen
Schule ja jetzt Ken auch noch kurz zu
Ende spielen eigentlich
oder
[Musik]
meine Schwester
an ich GL bra jetzt noch so 20 Minuten
halbe Stunde ich glaube 11 also das ist
wirklich gefressen od gefressen werden
ich fr noch nebenbei was ich nächste
Woche mache ich bin nächste
Woche
schon kein Problem wieder alles geregelt
hier Leute eentlich bin ich heftig in
solchen Spielen aber ich wollte ganz
kurz sagen ich mus
[Musik]
ganz diger auf Chickenburger ist immer
so eine komische Soße drauf so eine
weiße Bo
ein keine Wette ne nur wenn die
spieleen
kann nicht mehr ich kann nicht
mehr ja ich bin nicht so auf unterwegs
Lukas ja auf
[Musik]
IB und
ich
nicht ich bin übernächste Woche in
[Musik]
Mailand Montag Dienstag Mittwoch ich
nicht so geil ja ich bin nicht um die
Stadt anzugucken vielleicht ist das
keine weiße burgersoße ja
chill Burger
Gewicht bei solchen scheiß verliere ich
aber
immer halt die Schnauze ne SAS bin ich
schlecht mit so
einschätzschen meim Golf habe ich auch
noch ganz knapp geworden aber bei den
anderen
Sachen ich glaub bei diesem Spiel das W
die versage löschen da gewin mehrere
weiß
du ja ich
bin ich kann nicht mehr la ich Schrot
gleich diese Switch ne nein wir sind
beide rausgeflogen ich kann nicht ich
will Leute ihr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen mich fuckt gerade alles
ab diese scheiß Röhre kaufen W ne was
glaubst
Du e ich brauchte diese rühre was denst
neue
Bundestrainer keine Ahnung ich habe das
Deutschland Spiel ich mal geguckt also
Fußball juckt mich absolut gar nicht die
fußball ist so langweilig
geworden ich nehme jetzt auch noch kein
Item
weil nelmann wird auf keinen Fall W zu
jung dafür dum wenn er das
wahrscheinlich wenn dieses Video hier
auf Youtube online geht
sind sogar
schon im Urlaub und hoffentlich
geisteskrank
[Musik]
besoffen Lua ich war auch in Urlaub ne
ja klar and habe ich nicht
erwartet nein oh mein
[Musik]
Gott
boah ich habe extra ein paar nicht
aufgemacht weil ich mir nicht sicher war
bin immer so vorgegangen dass ich
geguckt dass ich nur mehr als die
anderen
hab Laser ich beende die scheiße jetzt
macht das gar kein Spaß immerchter ne
vorheragen geben halt wirklich auch
keinen Sinn weil ich halt jedes
Minispiel eigentlich B gewonnen hab das
Gute ist dass ich vor Luca bin und ich
werde Luca diese Röhre so wegschnappen
erinnerst du dich noch an das Video mit
messa ma ja ja wo ich auf diesem
Laufbahn war da habe ich s eigentlich
auch gesehen die hat mich auch angefragt
ich habe
abgesagt Laser weißt du warum ja wegen
Sport ja wenn ich so ein Scheiß wwürfel
oh mein Gott will ich gar nicht ja
wenigstens kriegst du was wieso hast
nicht deine goldrühre benutzt gerade
weil ich ziemlich n am sterern
[Musik]
bin wenn ich unter 10 Blöcke am stme
dann kann ich erst meine Würfel da
benutzener
Ring das bringt mal keine Ahnung der
meinte das bringt was wenn man relativ
nah am Wasser ist
[Musik]
oh schon geplatzt
Laser das Heß mir einfach 19 Sterne
jetzt abgezogen noch Ereignis F ach
Sandy
was komisch Sterne werden
getauscht nein jetzt ist zwei hinter
mir warum werden Sterne jetzt
getauscht werden ster jetzt wirklich
getauscht wuren gerade
ja bin schon drin ich ge offline das
war drauf geschissen ich geh jetzt
offline nein ander überleben was das
denn ja wo Denner die Leben
noch raus
jaer ich jetzt offline ich kann nicht
mehr ja wollen wir noch komm wir spielen
noch eine Runde halt die Fresse wir
spielen noch diese Runde vielleicht
kriegst du ja einen Stern guck mal
Donkey Kong ist sogar vor mir nein was
kriegst du denn jetzt
nichts vorher gesagt du
kriegst super Würfel oh mein
Gott aber du tauscht das Feld mit einem
Spieler deiner Wahl das ist krass dann
spielen wir bis zum
[Musik]
Ende Stk bedeutet das keine Ahnung pechf
aber auch Ehre dass er auf dich geht W
nam Stern ganz kurz
gucken Handys Runden dauern auch immer
ziemlich lang
ne aber ich habe diesen Scheiß minus
Ding 3
toll ey so krass cy West war einfach mit
seiner Mädel an diesem gemüseekbab heute
in E die andere Story erzähle ich im
Podcast ja ja cy West war einfach in
Berlin bei so einem gemüsekb heute und
ich bin einfach heute noch her gefahren
warum ist Cary West so oft in
[Musik]
Berlin
Ahnung ich habe immer so viele per zum
Stern ich habe so lange kein Stern mehr
[Musik]
bekommen
Stern
erhalten K
egal so Holzpferde oder so Pferdereiten
das hat nie Spaß
verstanden
Alter nein
remacht
[Musik]
Ende e ich habe die so auf dem letzten
Meter noch
guckt
die machen sogar Zielfoto ey die
Arme die Arme wie
a die ist so bedient die ist so bedient
ist einfach letzte
letzte ist nicht auf Stum einfach
[Musik]
aufgelegt
bitte
eine
Entschuldigung s tut mir leid ja
[Musik]
wirklich
ja aber ich bin ja kein
Wicher Klau mir mein Stern zurück
GU ich sag doch
das do kein Wicher ich bin doch da Leute
jetzt haben wir beide
50 le ich schwöre es dir ne in dem
Moment als du auf Feld gegangen bist war
mein Kopf unten ich habe vor dieser
Zeremonie nichts mitbekommen weil ich
ganz genau wusste was passiert es war
klar es war mir noch nie
klarer warum sagen jetzt Leute hol sie
doch ab hol Sander doch ab diger dieses
verdammte Büro von S in
bifeld ich bin in Köln da bin ich erst
zwei Stunden unterwegs und die wohnen
von ihrem Büro zu
sich Minuten vielleicht was schätzt du
wie lange wie lange man zu Fuß braucht
von mir bis zum Büro weiß die Strecke zu
Fuß
ja nicht ja mal diger sehr sehr
lang was glaubst Du also ich bin ja
gejogt die Strecke und das waren so 25
Minuten Hal Stunde vielleicht zu Fuß 52
Minuten
Start das geht
sch wie dumm oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott
l nein
ich
nein wenn die gegen Peach verliert
ne das W so lach das W einfach traurig
wenn sie gen verliert gegen einen Bot
der auf Normal
ist die läuft
Schneeball
die
Taschenmuschi Leute ich guck gleich
einfach ob hier ein ecoooter steht ich
auch man kann ich jetzt auch gucken ob
bei dir da einer
[Musik]
ist ich hätte einfach ich hätte einfach
mit meinem eigenen kommen sollen echt so
warum machst du das nicht ich hab
vergessen oder du solltest den immer mal
im Office stehen lassen
ja ne das mit in solchen Situation dass
Du dann immer darauf zurückgreifen
kannst und wenn du dann mit dem nach
Hause fährst das nächste Mal Office
fährst mit Auto wahrscheinlich dann
kannst wieder in Kofferraum packen und
mitnehmen weißt
du also Peach ne die schlage ich halt
auch zusammen
jetzt jetzt irgendwie aber die Sache
ist Donkey Kong erster PE und ich haben
beide drei Sterne und du hast n zwei
wenn du ein hast bist ja auch schon
wieder mit
[Musik]
dabeiel hat sich schon wieder verletzt
so ein
Idiot
[Musik]
Dritter ja hab doch gesagt Leute ich war
weg Glückwunsch Sandy ich war weg
Glückwunsch gut
gemacht
die
[Musik]
schöner ich muss jetzt meine Items mal
langsam
benutzen bist du denn
[Musik]
entfernt ich mach jetzt
einfach ein
Z du kannst do B Zeh ja ja ist das
sinnvollste glaube ich ich bin 66 Sterne
bis zum 36 Felder zum
Stern was passiert
jetzt ach wird wieder getauscht das ist
doch nicht wahr du bist jetzt direkt am
Stern jo bin ich aber dadurch dass ich
als Letzter Würfel habe ich dann nie die
Chance oh Donkey Kong alleine das hat
wir noch
keinm Laser ich setze auf
dich
Idioten
danke schön kein Problem
Freunde mein
Gott weil sie den emoji benutzt
Hater Peach die nehmen die lassen wir
noch richtig durch
oderer Taus jetzt wieder
wie viel bin ich vom Stern
entfernt Bo diger das ist so frech
Sandra wird einfach erste Sandra wird
erste nein werde ich nicht diger du
kaufst den ST du bist an doy Kong vorbei
dann aber er hat mehr Münzen ja muss zum
letzten minpiel noch
rasieren ja diese es gibt auch noch
diese korrupten Dinger Leute gedacht ich
noch so weit bringe in let spielen
einfach alles auseinander genommen oh
Duell möchtest du eine Münze setzen
ja bist du dumm
so setzt doch alle deine ach so er gibt
ja gar keinen Sinn ich hab falsch
gemacht oder du hast Angst jetzt spielen
wir um zwei Münzen ein Spiel diger wir
spielen um zwei
Münzen ja Laser ich habe es nicht
gerereilt
also da bin ich jetzt
[Musik]
raus was diger schon korrupt bisschen
ne das
krank ja hä das verstehe ich ja gar
nicht
Leute
h wann ist denn der perfekte
Zeitpunkt
jetzt zwei Münzen gewonnen diger ich
komme ja wieder nicht zum Stern ist halt
das Ding ich habe 20 Schritte die ich
gehen muss und ich schaffe maximal
[Musik]
ganz
kurz was ist mit dem Marathon er Oktober
ich laauf den Marathon aber Halbmarathon
nicht ganz
Marathon wir wollten ja ursprünglich
hatten wir einen Monat hatten wir
geplant den Marathon zu Lauf das auch so
angekündigt das istens auch keine
irgendwie mit dem Halbmarathon oder mit
der Stadt Köln oder so wir haben einfach
nur Bock drauf
nee aber Marathon hätten wir auf gar
keinen Fall geschafft mit dem Training
weil das sind also wie im echten Sport
ich bin einfach nur 32 m geflogen das
sind 40 km oder 4 deswegen laufen jetzt
nur 22 die letzte Runde Leute also wenn
gleich das Minispiel kommt Leute wenn
das Minispiel kommt R nimmt alle eure
Kohle wenn ihr Eier habt wenn ihr Eier
habt alle alle coins setzener setzt eine
de money wir sind schon wieder soweit ja
okay du hast nur 21 mehr können wir
nicht setzen
ja
nein
nein mein Gott ich habe den selben füler
gebaut ich bin falsch gelaufen du auch
ja glaub ich schaff trotzdem vy ja msste
ich
eigentlich oh mein
Gott das war
aber okay Leute jetzt kommt die letzte
Runde ja 19 Sterne ich schaffe es nicht
ich schaffe das nicht ich kann ja auch
nicht zwei Items nehmen geh noch mal all
in ja z aber bringt mir ja nichts ich
habe ja keine Röhren die Röhren sind das
wichtigste Donkey Kong hat die meisten
Sterne aber wir haben zum Glück noch
diese
belohnungsdinger wer
soll ich den Zufall entscheiden lassen
Sandy dann bin ich auch ich e mach auf
Zufall okay ich bin korrekt ich ma auf
Zufall ich bin
okay aber die hat auch verdient muss man
sagen aber warum hast
genommen ich habe Stern genommen oh mein
Gott ich dachte gerade ich habe Münzen
genommen oh
glücksfeld ja diger ich krieg wieder n
mzenzeug
damit brst du irgendwelche Supplements
für den Muskel
aufbau Proteinpulver so handpreinpulver
habe ich schon mal erzählt ansonsten
nicht Leute okay letztes Spiel 3400000
auf mich ihr seid
bescheuert ich das verliere soll ich mal
absichtig verlieren hab ihr alle eure
Münzen verloren
ne letztes Spiel wir rasieren
natürlich ich schwöre mein Controller
ist
kaputt ja okay Laser hat einfach
gewonnen du bist Universum
Bruder Ciao dier ich B einfach wel bin
einfach weltil
[Musik]
gelandet aber Donkey Kong war auch im
Weltall okay krass ja okay das war jetzt
wohl das letzte Minispiel das heißt
jetzt wird
ausgewählt
wer gewonnen hat es sind alle Runden
gespielt tolle Partien wer wird den
Gruppensieg davon tragen gehen wir als
erstes die Boni durch als erstes
vergeben wir jetzt den
itemonus wer auf gar keinen Fall ich
bekommen die meisten Items hast sa du
eingesetetzt PE
Peach hat so viele Items gekauft ich
weiß gar nicht D SAS gibt meine einlösen
können
ereignisbonus ich da gibt
[Musik]
spielbonus
es gab nur zwei mir mir bringt du hast
trotzdem gewonnen weil du die meisten
Münzen
[Musik]
hast
ja
schön ich hat aberleich viele Sterne
so aber mir bringt es
nichts dass ich jetzt die meisten
Minispiele gewonnen ich habe fast jedes
Minispiel gewonnen ja krass war auf
jeden Fall lustig Freunde die beste
Nacht eures ganzen Lebens die werde ich
nich jetzt auch haben Sandra Liegestütze
alle erinnern mich daran du musst noch
20 Liegestütze machen nein nein doch
Sand W sch sieht nicht ja Sandy man
sieht es nicht ja richtig ich kann die
nicht
vorstellen ich habe schon mal eine
gemacht ich glaube das nicht ich glaube
nicht dass sie da eine gemacht hat
ach leute das ist so Quatsch das ist so
scam dass du da gerade Liegestütz machst
Sandy ja das ist halt meine
Kameraeinstellung Bruder was soll ich da
machen
piss ja ich geh jetzt offline Leute es
okay Leute wirenden den Stream wir
hoffen es hat euch gefallen haut rein
wir sehen uns die Tage
[Musik]
wieder